[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont la la la la la
j'ai les mains gelées
il fait très très froid dans le ciel ou
we will à moi moi je descends envie de
8,8 me réchauffer chez des petits
copains petit louis et mirabel au où il
ne traîne pas trop nounours congo sinon
je pars sans toi oui oui je suis chez
son coiffeur
asseyez-vous à monsieur gros vous je
vous croise quelques j'en ai fini
monsieur petit louis haut
voilà monsieur vous êtes debout
vous voulez une friction oui s'il vous
plaît mais moi elle me rappelle je
voudrais de l'autre colonne qui sent bon
et voilà et ça fait combien mademoiselle
cette fois monsieur et n'oubliez pas le
service ont toujours le char vie voilà
merci monsieur moi je suis fan il a de
la force vote raciste au veau mais c'est
bruyant
chaque fois et demie en finale des
frises à la fois ce qu'il y a deux lieux
j'ai beaucoup de sous là ça suffit cette
boue
[Musique]
maintenant la remise non sur le côté par
pitié pas de re en millions sur le
compte et enfin je serai
[Musique]
que le mot le voilà patron j'arrive vous
êtes de vilains garnements
allez vous coucher tout seul tout de
suite je suis très fâché avec vous olala
c'est pas joli pas content du tout
content du tout du tout du tout au locle
alors
[Musique]
petit louis et mirabel ont été très
méchant il ne faut jamais se battre
même quand on joue gros ce jour c'est
bien triste
il a beaucoup de peine tu es dans un bel
état gros jour 6 ou été très coquin et
bien pour les punir
nous ne viendrons pas les voir demain
soir viendra pas mes 6 ans âge
nous reviendrons après demain viendra
bonnut des enfants produits embrassez
vos parents et aller vite au lit ouais
mais surtout ne vous battez pas bon
c'est promis à bientôt bientôt
[Musique]